to answer those questions for fake
ramaswamy joins us he is of course
running for president he's also a Long
Time Finance guy venture capitalist
knows the industry well joins us tonight
Vic thank you so much for coming on so
first just and I and I know these These
are complicated questions but just
assess if you will
how most people experience the news that
the government is bailing out a bank
where 95 of the deposits were over 250
000 deposits put there by people who pay
half the tax rate you do because they
benefit from the carried interest
loophole that does look a little rigged
I'm just throwing that out there
oh it's absolutely rig Tucker there's a
two rule system in this country there's
the rule for the favorite class and then
the rules for everybody else the rules
for everybody else is 250 000 maximum
but this was really a bailout of Silicon
Valley itself the tech startups who made
disastrous financial decisions to bank
as much as they did with Silicon Valley
Bank but what does the federal
government say don't worry about it
we're going to come in and save you even
companies like Roku that staggeringly
had like over 480 million dollars that's
unconscionable yet what we say is that's
okay you get to keep making those
disastrous decisions now Tucker the
logic and actually many of these Venture
capitalists that invested in these
companies they had a perverse incentive
to fear monger and create the conditions
for a bank run because the more likely a
bank run was the more likely it was that
they would get that bailout for those
Tech startups on Sunday night so kudos
to them for playing crony capitalism
well that's exactly what they got done
but you think about this you had a
really good point there I can't think of
a more disastrous way to shake take
confidence than to call any emergency
meeting on Sunday night and say Here's a
bank that we told you for the longest
time was not systemically important that
itself claimed that it wasn't
systemically important but now we're
going to use a designation of calling it
systemically important to make a bailout
to its depositors so actually I think
that this is a game that is a downward
March just like ESG came out of the 2008
financial crisis Central Bank digital
currencies are what's going to come out
of this next one and I think that this
is something that every Republican
frankly every American needs to be clear
about we have to say absolutely not to
that level of social credit scoring that
could unfold on the back of this and you
mark my words it's marking yours as well
this is likely where this is heading
it's a longer term game to a disaster
so very quickly how long before people
start to ask okay these long-term
treasuries now that interest rates have
gone up are worth less than we thought
they were who else is holding huge I
mean the FED itself and what other banks
are counting these as cash equivalents
like how nervous should we be
look I think this is there's a sin a lot
of sins to pay for years of actually
skiing on artificial snow now the snow
machine turned off now the real real
evidence actually starts the surface and
Tucker the other thing I'll tell you is
even over the weekend right I got calls
from Silicon Valley Elites okay it's
saying that you know what I was going to
support you people in the billionaire
class whatever but you're speaking out
about this speaking this openly no I'm
going to lose donor support my view is
you know what this is a moment for a
Grassroots Uprising that's why I mean
look I've put in eight figures into this
campaign myself but it's going to have
to be Grassroots bottom up and so
vivek2024.com let's actually get the
Grassroots Uprising going instead of
actually the the one-sided Silicon
Valley agenda here well this is the kind
of thing that you know provokes
uprisings I would say uh Vivek thank you
so much thanks for joining us tonight
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight